going now that the story of a woman
taking power from men who have had it
over her for so long would be so
relevant right now but there's no way
you could have known that going into
this and what do you and what do you
think about that now oh my god we got we
we did this there couldn't be a better
time for this movie to come out I mean
we started making it three years ago and
then with the election and with
everything that's going on with this
movement and watching you know this
amazing watching this abuse and and
manipulation through the lens of a woman
who's regaining her own power it just
couldn't be a better time for this film
the conversation of either's women in
film and and leads and heroes but this
is different because the women in this
movie take a lot of abuse but women in
this movie also dish out brutality yes
it's even a frost that you get it yeah
this is it's a very empowering almost
healing other than terrible torture
scenes yeah film to watch these women be
used and abused and turned the whole
thing on their head and end up regaining
their freedom and coming out on top by
using their their intelligence yeah and
watching the men that's around Jen's
character under estimate and also on the
Americans thought underestimate the
power yeah and the intelligence it's
that we've all we've all seen many spy
films this is the first time we that I
think I've seen it a long time wherever
where the sex is not sexy no it is not
no it's not be part of these this genre
it was it was a really big conversation
between Francis and I you know there
really is actually no nudity in a sexual
context the nudity is really used to
show the brutality and it's it's
devastating and and you made and and
really troubling so not for the weak
mind because it was it was it easier to
do neut in it and in a way or so I mean
I didn't
yeah I didn't ready to do nudity in a
sexual context maybe one day I will I
didn't feel ready at the time but I
don't know what would be hard are
getting
a nude scene or stripping naked in front
of an actual classroom it's really good
the trick I mean the treatment of it as
you say it's not there to titillate the
audience and and I think that the
intention behind you know graphic scenes
in movies for an actor they they often
become about what's the expectation and
I think if someone says you it's really
important that that you're sexy and that
this is I think that's terrifying
yeah for an actor to do whereas at least
this is there's attention and
manipulation and drama behind the scenes
that that are in this movie in that
regard I mean it's interesting for me to
look at the whole movie and I mean thank
God I just kept in to thank God I'm not
playing your character and Hollywood has
I mean I know you didn't set out to make
a political movie but Holly was a very
long history of creating films where you
do not root for the Russian yeah I mean
we're during the Cuban Missile Crisis
knew Octopussy yeah I mean us-russian
relations have fascinated audiences for
decades it's been fueled a material for
books and movies for so long and then a
year ago it it resurges it was it's
constantly fascinating you had no idea
that you were getting into all of this
then you make a movie and it's relevant
across the board right amazing thank you
very much appreciate